this week President Trump welcomes some
of the nation's truckers to the South
Lawn of the White House she thanked them
and handed them gold keys a token of
appreciation for their essential work
during the current crisis the trucking
industry has taken an uneven hit from
the pandemic drivers who haul fuel or
carry parts to factories have seen
demand plummets but those who transport
food and medical supplies are busier
than ever for truckers still at work it
means long hours and a world that has
suddenly become far less welcoming Kris
Van Cleave has the story we caught up
with Angie and Larry Baum on Interstate
81 near Christiansburg Virginia Angie
what's the biggest difference you notice
when you're driving now the biggest
thing is a lot less cars on the road a
lot more truck drivers they're bound for
Nashville and then on to Rialto
California with a load of packages
through their married to the road blog
the couple's documenting how life has
changed since coronavirus are you doing
this is like our supply we've got my
face mask there and our Purell we keep
it with us all times for those handy and
this gave us big bucks gloves what's the
hardest part of your job now trying to
stay safe I here's the biggest thing
finding bathrooms showers and a place to
rest has gotten harder as many small
truck stops and some rest stops are
closed about the only restaurants open
now or drive throughs and big rigs don't
fit have there been times where you just
haven't been able to get dinner I think
we went for almost two weeks where there
was you know two or three nights that we
didn't mean truckers move 71 percent of
all domestic Freight and virtually all
consumer goods they are essential
workers especially now but a shuttered
economy means fewer products need to be
hauled and less work for Paul IV in
California I you know it's gonna take me
three days to get reloaded out of
California and usually takes me one day
Dillon Francis just finished trucking
school he has a job lined up but can't
start because his DMV is closed it's
extremely frustrating I was ready to
work I was ready to do something whites
travel center calls itself the largest
truck stop on the East Coast it's
staying open and busy stepping up its
sanitation efforts and has an on-site
urgent care but drivers worry you're
scared to even go inside there we're
keeping our distances with
see that scared to touch anything do you
guys worry about getting sick he's me
more than him because he's got a
compromised immune system he doesn't get
out of the truck unless it's to pump gas
so it's weighing on you a lot a lot yeah
my kids are over it does it make you
think about just staying home yeah wish
we could but for now their trailers are
full they'll keep on driving hoping we
all outrun coronavirus soon for CBS this
morning Saturday Kris Van Cleave
Christiansburg Virginia it is hard to
see Dana I mean these are the people
some of the people holding society
together right now when they can't get
dinner or food it is very difficult to
hear I mean they're frontline workers in
a very different way you're right where
would we be without them bringing the
goods to us especially now when so many
more that we need to come we can't just
go get the normal way we do a great
story by Chris as well